- I can't speak for anybody
else's experience obviously,
but mine was that, Josh
and I have been together
for 11 years and I was really-
- That's crazy.
- Thank you, yeah.
(audience applauding)
- That's an amazing thing, that long.
- And he is an incredibly
quiet person who hates cameras
and hates the limelight;
very similar to my parents,
very similar to my brothers the same way.
- Oh, wow.
- So whenever they would come
to premieres or come to
work with me or meet friends
or go out to dinner, but
especially premieres,
we would do this dance
where like, the car pulls up
and they all get out and go
through the side entrance
and grab popcorn and drinks.
And they're like, "You
can do as many interviews
as you need to do on that red carpet,
but we do not want any part of cameras.
We love our privacy and
we'll see you at the seats."
So, when I was putting-
- That's great.
- this memoir together...
It is very grounding,
- Yeah.
- And my parents are immigrants.
So, their whole perspective
- And you have people wanting
to suck up the attention
you know what I'm saying, it's
just like, let me do my job
and you do your thing.
- Yeah. I wanted to just be respectful
of my parents and Josh and my brother.
So when I was putting this
memoir together, I'm like
I wanna make people laugh.
I wanna take them on this
crazy journey that I've had
through all these different jobs.
And I said to my parents
can I tell your immigration
story, how you came to America?
My dad came here with $12 in his pocket.
- Yeah.
- And just the likelihood that
I would be an actor or work
in The White House, I'm like,
I wanna connect those dots.
And for Josh, I said, the
way we met was so ridiculous
and funny, and our
friends love this story.
I'd love to share it
with the readers as well.
The way that we met was
over a bunch of Coors Lights and NASCAR.
And it's just such an absurd
st- I did not grow up.
(audience laughing)
My dad likes Coors Light, but I grew up,
I did not grow up with NASCAR.
- That was so far from what I thought-
- You thought? Yeah.
(audience laughing and clapping)
- It was like all of a
sudden we just became BFF's.
- So I hear that a lot.
- Are you a member of my family?
(Kal laughs)
- Might be close.
So Josh is from Mississippi.
I'm from New Jersey.
- Oh I love Mississippi.
- We met when we were both
living in DC when I was working
at The White House.
And you only have one day off really
when you're a White House staffer
and it was a Sunday,
- I feel like that's what it's like
in the entertainment industry.
(Kelly laughs)
- It, totally, yes.
Except entertainers have a
little more job stability
and it's a little more lucrative.
- Sometimes.
- Sometimes, that's true.
(Kelly laughs)
You can fall harder too.
So we had met and it was
basically our second date.
And I was like
why don't you just come
over and watch some TV?
So this dude rolls over
to my apartment with an
18 pack of Coors Light.
- Love. Classy.
- But then I had the TV
had "SpongeBob Squarepants"
on cause I'm a romantic and
he rolls in and he changes it
to a NASCAR race.
- Oh my God.
- And I just thought to myself, oh, well,
this guy's obviously gonna be leaving
in 20 minutes with 16 of those beers
(Kelly laughs)
because I don't know
anything about NASCAR.
And it turned out that as
we started watching the race
and talking about NASCAR,
we also started talking
about camping.
And so he grew up in rural Mississippi,
- I love camping.
- Family didn't have a lot of money.
Their family vacations were
camping trips to races.
- Yeah, oh that's cool.
- And in my case, my
parents are immigrants.
My dad moved here with very little.
So our family vacations
were also camping trips
to different parks in
Pennsylvania or upstate New York.
- Yeah
- And so suddenly we were
bonding off of that race.
- That commonality.
- And that commonality of that experience.
- Yeah.
- And so that was the
entry point to the story
that, it's Chapter 18, about
like so many people meet
their significant other in ways
that you would never expect.
Like, literally my first thought was
this dude's gonna leave soon..
(Kelly laughs)
..because we have nothing in common.
- Because I dunno anything about this.
- But now, you know, I've gone to a bunch
of NASCAR races and I'm
following drivers, yeah.
- It's fun.
(audience clapping)
- It is really fun.
- Just, the hang is fun.
- Have you been to a race this season?
- Have I been to? Not
recently since COVID,
but yes I've been to several races.
My family's very into, they
live in North Carolina.
- Okay, do you have a driver?
- That's like the hub.
Well, I have one driver
that I've loved and that's
because he drove me
around and didn't kill me,
(Kal laughs)
- That's a good bench for it.
- That's Jimmy Johnson.
- Oh nice, yeah.
- He is my favorite, but
that's just because he
didn't kill me.
And I am not a fan of speed like that.
- Yeah.
- I am very chill.
- Uh huh.
- I like like a, Hey, I like, like a ride.
- Like cruising.
- Yeah, with a great soundtrack.
- Yeah.
- I'm not in getting anywhere fast.
- Nope.
- Yeah, I feel that.
- So you said in the book that
you applied online to work
at The White House,
which I think is awesome.
Is there somewhere I
can go online to apply
to work at The White House?
- There was, I don't know if there is in
the current administration.
I mean, this is-
- I'd be really good.
- I think this is like Chapter 11
in the book or something where I was like
I guess I do need to come clean
about how I actually, everybody asks
how did you end up working
at The White House?
And I did volunteer for
the campaign for about
a year and a half, but when it
came time to, the Obama's win
and the he's the president
elect, and the campaign
sends around this email that says
"if you'd like to work for the
administration, you fill out-
you upload your resume to a
website called change.gov."
And so I thought, okay,
well I guess I'll do that.
And if I'm qualified,
somebody will call me.
And I didn't think the
logical thing- look as artists
we don't apply for
traditional jobs, right.
- Yeah.
- So of course I had
heard, like, yeah, people-
- Well you do, things are going wrong.
(audience laughing)
- Which is fine too, but you
fill out your resume and then
you're supposed to call people
know and use your networks to
highlight that you applied.
I didn't know any of this.
So I fill out my resume on change.gov.
I put it up there.
The only person I told was my
manager, my acting manager.
And I said, Hey, I might take a sabbatical
from my first love and
try this crazy thing.
If I get this job.
And my manager is every character
from the TV show entourage
in one person.
(Kelly and audience laugh)
- That's amazing.
- He's a lion with the heart of gold.
So he goes, "okay, whatever.
You're not gonna do that."
And then he goes, "but
if you do, great" and-
- Thanks for the support.
- Well it's, you know,
cut to inauguration,
I was invited to speak
at the inaugural concert
on the steps of the Lincoln Memorial.
You get to bring your friends
and family backstage to
meet the new first incoming first family.
- All of yours were hiding,
they didn't wanna be seen.
(audience and Kelly laugh)
- It's funny you say that, they were like,
"are there cameras there?"
And I was like, "well,
it's a concert, like, yeah.
- It's the first black
president's inaugural concert
on these steps of the Lincoln Memorial."
- I think they capture it.
- There are cameras.
They said, "what about backstage?"
And I said, "no", they're like, "great."
So they did come.
- I love that.
- But Mrs. Obama who I hadn't met before,
you know, she's shaking hands.
And she meets my parents
and my brother and my manager's with us.
And she says, I hope you stay involved.
And I said, yeah, no, I
definitely plan on it.
And he says, "well, you know
Kal applied for a job, right?"
And I was like, no, no, no, no, no.
This is not how this works, stop, stop.
- Oh.
- And she says, "what do you mean?"
And he goes, "yeah."
"He applied for a job at The White House
and nobody even called him back."
(audience laughs)
- Oh my God, how far have
you dug into the ground
to get away, escape from this moment?
- Oh, I was horrified.
Again, remember every
character from entourage right.
In one.
So I was like, "Dan, please stop."
And she goes, "what do you mean?
Who did you apply with?"
And I said, "I put my
resume on change.gov."
(Kelly and audience laughs)
And that's the moment I realized
that I was kind of a dummy,
- Maybe.
- And she called the
president over and says
"tell him what you just told me."
(audience laughing)
- Cause she's like, this is unbelievable.
- She, by the way, we all know this now
that it's been so many years,
but Mrs. Obama has a very
low threshold for (bleep)
- And it's amazing and she's
so sweet and funny too.
- Absolutely.
- Yeah, yeah. I love that
your manager went from like
you're not gonna do, it's like,
well, you didn't hire him.
So...
- Yeah, yeah, yeah, exactly.
- And he's overqualified.
(audience applauds)
- It's like, I love it.